cursive is becoming something of a lost
art most schools are now reluctant to
teach it
most of us input data via a keyboard and
there's just not that much incentive to
use handwriting at all let alone to join
up neatly but this is a big shame not
only because cursive looks nice not only
because it's a shame when anything dies
out but also because cursive could
actually have a lot of very important
benefits for the brain especially in
developing brains that's because this is
one way that you can practice finer
motor control unless you happen to sew
or paint or unless US surgeon chances
are you don't practice the skill very
much and it's a big skill to be lost and
this can really hold you back especially
when it comes to speaking fluently and
confidently that's because the premotor
cortex one part of the brain that's
responsible for planning movements
actually plays a very big role in
speaking and even in understanding
speech and writing consider the case of
one small boy outlined in the book the
brain that changes itself so this boy
suffered from jerky writing poor
comprehension muddled speech he'd often
get confused
so he attended a special school called
the Aerosmith school the NR Smith school
is an organization that was set up by
Barbra Aerosmith young to help children
with learning disabilities after she
overcame her own learning challenges and
one of the exercises this school tasked
him with was to trace detailed images
what's remarkable is that this exercise
in no time at all not only improved his
ability to write but also his ability to
speak confidently and even understand
what other people were saying he could
speak in much longer sentences he
wouldn't get confused and he became far
more eloquent and outgoing and that same
exercise has been used to improve verbal
fluency and many others and we have
every reason to suspect that it would
also be effective at improving verbal
fluency for people who don't have any
learning difficulties this could help
you to become more persuasive more
compelling more charismatic all of which
can help to get ahead in a number of
different fields or what's going on well
during speech we need to convert symbols
which are letters and sounds into
movements of our lips and tongue this
requires rapid processing and planning
and that's where the premotor cortex
comes in and that's why I should come as
no surprise really they're sufficiently
training the premotor cortex would
improve your ability to speak and
reading might be improved because you
use the premotor cortex in order to move
your eyes across the page without the
premotor cortex working properly you can
jump around and struggle to focus
because you can't plan that movement
ahead of time the premotor cortex might
play a role in speech perception because
we kind of mouthed the words that we
hear in order to better understand them
this happens unconsciously don't notice
yourself doing it that's the view
perforce at least by the embodied
cognition school of thought and this is
just one case of course but it makes a
lot of sense given that we know there is
a link between the premotor cortex and a
verbal fluency and that writing and
similar tasks can strengthen this area
by the end it's not only normalized the
boys reading and speaking for fishin see
but he actually exceeded the average for
his age group so what can we take from
this well basically we should be writing
in cursive or at least practicing some
kind of fine articulate movement and it
makes sense that you really should do
this most of us do not if you type that
doesn't count if you don't try
practicing writing by hand then maybe
should try sewing or coloring in that
can also be highly relaxing and if you
want to get extra points then try using
your non-dominant hand to train
ambidexterity and to thicken that corpus
callosum that could increase creativity
and I've spoken on it at length in other
videos whatever you do practice
dexterity because the results are
far-reaching thanks son for watching
guys hope fans video useful and
interesting just a quick tip thought I'd
share as I found it really interesting
let me know down below if you've done
anything to improve your verbal fluency
and how you practice using dexterity in
your hands
got lots of more brain tips fitness tips
productivity tips all on the way so if
that sounds good thanks a ton for
watching and I'll see you next time bye
for now
you